the official death toll stands at 59
this morning more than 500 were hurt it
was the deadliest u.s. attack since 9/11
people in Las Vegas and around the
country held vigils last night to honor
the victims nor O'Donnell is near the
scene of the shootings in Las Vegas nor
a good morning hey good morning to you
bianna that's right it's been more than
24 hours since the attack and we are
learning new details about the people
who died they came from all across the
US and Canada the ones who've been
identified reportedly range in age from
20 to 57 years old many were surrounded
by friends and family at that Country
Music Festival
they include Jenny parks a mother of two
married to her childhood sweetheart she
was a kindergarten teacher
Adrienne Murphy from Alaska died in the
arms of a longtime friend who calls him
quote a giant teddy bear with a huge
heart and 20 year old Bailey Schweitzer
was at the concert with her mother and
best friend her boss told us she
brightened everyone's day agent ideas is
at a memorial for the victims on the Las
Vegas Strip
Adriana good morning Nora this memorial
has just been growing and the survivors
tell us they've been scarred both
physically and mentally by this attack
last night we met page Melanson a former
Miss Las Vegas she was at the concert
with her mother both were shot Paige was
grazed but her mother took a direct hit
the bullet entered her mother's shoulder
and went down to her abdomen Paige told
us what it was like to have to leave her
mother at the scene a retired
firefighter crawled his way over to us
because obviously he saw we were in
hysteria and she said that he was
retired firefighter and he was going to
stay with my mom and he said if we
wanted to live that we needed to run for
our lives and we needed to get out that
was as you can imagine probably one of
the hardest decisions
I ever made in my entire life and my
mother is laying there on the ground and
of course I didn't want to leave her but
I mean in order to protect even myself
and the people I was with it was it was
best to get out of there for 11 hours
after that Paige didn't know where her
mother was or if she'd even survived the
two were reunited last night at the
hospital and Paige said it was an
enormous relief just to see her mother
awake Paige received stitches for her
elbow wound and her mother's expected to
get a second surgery today but as
responsive Nora Adriana
thank you so much